(INTRO)J'ai un délire depuis que je suis petit, c'est de savoir la valeur
d'un objet. Quand je vois un truc et que j'ai aucune idée de combien il coûte j'ai envie de
savoir combien il coûte et combien il a coûté a
produire. Voilà, un délire chelou, heu,  mais ce... ça m'amuse. Quand j'avais 8 ans par exemple je me
baladais comme ça dans la rue avec Mauricette ma grand-mère j'faisais
"ah la la il fait beau c'est beau je trébuchais sur un truc et là par terre et là hop !
Il y avait ta mère en slip comme ça sur le trottoir et là j'retournais voir ma grand-mère et je faisais :
"Mamy, ça coûte combien ça ?" et ma grand-mère me disait : "je sais pas il doit coûter aux alentours de
15 ou 20 ou 10 €
C'est un jeu", " mais Mamy tu donnes une fourchette super large !" " Ta gueule."
Je me cache derrière mon micro j'ai honte de cette prestation quelque peu, heu... nulle
Mais bon vous me pardonnerez bien sûr en voyant que je ne parlais pas en réalité
derrière ce micro. Ca marche à tous les coups. Bref, cette histoire de merde c'était
juste pour introduire ce site " THE RIGHT PRICE GAME.com", alors il est en anglais on
sait pas pourquoi, alors qu'c'est un français, l'un d'entre vous, qui s'appelle Joe
d'ailleurs, qui l'a fait. Ok play !
Bon voilà bon c'est comme les jeux où tu dois deviner le prix où il y a deux objets
faut deviner lequel est le moins cher, lequel est le plus cher, ou lequel
vaut x dollars. Voilà ! C'est des articles Amazon à chaque fois,
par exemple entre un Zippo, donc un briquet qui fait du feu et une
Fluxmob, donc c'est un chargeur externe, lequel vaut 13 dollars
Attends je comprend pas. Pour moi aucun des
deux ne peux valoir 13 dollars sauf si j'ai mal compris un produit. Une
batterie ça peut pas valoir 13 dollars, donc c'est forcément ça. Mais un Zippo mec ? Ah c'est juste
la couverture orange du Zippo ! Ok on a 1 point ! Quel produit vaut le
plus cher ? "Amazon New AWS lot Button"
Oh putain j'ai réussi y a pas longtemps mais j'ai rien compris à ce que c'était et je
crois que c'est hyper cher ou une paire de Ray-Ban bah c'est ça de base. Bah voilà ! Pu-
-tain ! Oh, ça commence mal oh ça va m'énerver oh putain mec je je baisse
Tu le vois mon short était là, je l'ai baissé. Quand un homme fait ça il est
très énervé. Quel produit vaut le moins cher ? Un oreiller ignoble
en passant, ou un emoji smiley
émoticône de 32 cm *rires*
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH ! l'emoji ! Comment cet emoji peut valoir si peut cher
putain... ça a changé l'emoji, la mec c'est hyper dur
Lequel est le moins cher ? Un adorable petit animal
sur lequel est posé ton
smartphone
on dirait que ça fait cette taille mais vraiment ça fait cette taille en réalité
ouuu, une...
...pour connecter ta douche
...c'est tout. C'est ma description de cet objet achetez en plein, hein ! Lequel vaut le moins cher
une baleine qui va sous l'eau ?! Elle va sous l'eau ?! Attention
ça celle là, elle va sous l'eau, parce qu'il y a des baleines qui vont pas sous l'eau
ou ! Une... c'est quoi ça ? C'est des instruments de géomérie ou
on fait l'amour et ça a donné ça ? Je comprend pas, mec. Lequel vaut le moins cher ?
Alors vu la complexité de cet objet je dirais la baleine quand même,même si elle va sous l'eau
Quand même le repère orthonormé qui a baisé avec une équerre, tu sais, intestable.
Alors lequel vaut le moins cher ? Une GoPro... ah je crois que c'est juste le truc que tu colles à ta planche,
avant d'mettre la GoPro. Ou les chouettes, belles de Stephen Johnston.
Le truc GoPro vaut moins cher.
Oh c'est le même prix ! Ohh on fait des bailles un peu vilains là du côté de Joe !
"Qu'est-ce qui vaut le plus cher ?" Un Zarapack ? C'est juste un sac Zara, en tissu, ou "8 Piece Tegu Pocket
Pouch Magnetic Wooden Block". Donc c'est des cubes magnétiques.
Ça vaut plus cher que le truc Zara le truc magnétique.
Oui ! Waoouuuhhhh !
Alors ? Vous vous foutiez de ma g*eule avec mon histoire de m*rde là où j'ai trébuché sur un jeu de société
quand j'étais petit ! Eh bah elle est faute mon pote mais j'me dém*rde quand même très bien aujourd'hui.
Et c'est beau de l'admettre. Ok ! Ok ok attention on se concentre. On est à 4 bonnes réponses d'affilée,
c'est la folie. "Quel objet vaut 19$ ?". Un jouet d'un mec dans une voiture, ou un radio-réveil
"Elle est simple et facile à utiliser pour cuisiner, aller en cours, ou faire de la gym". *rire*
Est-ce que cette horloge peut valoir 19$ et la réponse est oui !
Waoouuhh !
Mec, je suis on fire, c'est un truc de ouf ! c'est la première fois de ma vie qu'une vidéo commence
aussi bien ! Pour fêter ça, petit tour de magie que personne ne connait en France, et qui est dangereux
donc ne le faites pas chez vous. J'vais faire une boule de feu attention. Ça charge en gaz. Ça pue.
Ohh il était beau !!
"Quel produit vaut 383$ ?". Un KitchenAid, ça ça vaut.. Mec, vous moquez pas de moi j'ai acheté un Cookeo
Parce que je me disais, un moment j'aimerai faire d'la cook, d'la cuisine, pas la poudre qui te fait exciter
et mourir 2 jours après, tu mets les carottes dans le Cookeo comme ça, tu lances, tu reviens après, c'est
propre, achetez des Cookeos bien sûr, placement de produits, on est tipars !
Bref en cherchant j'avais vu ce truc, KitchenAid, ça vaut hy-per-cher. Lequel vaut 383$, C'est le KitchenAid. Voilà.
Merci ! "Lequel est plus cher ?". "Riedel Swan Decanter", c'est quoi ? Ou, un petit oreiller pour voyager *rire*
C'est celui-là j'dirai mais j'pense qu'il y a un piège. Oh nan y'a pas de piège !
C'est quoi cet objet à 500$ ? Ok "Lequel vaut le moins cher". Mec, on est sur une série de bonnes réponses,
c'est colossal ce qu'il s'passe. Là j'appelle Youtube ils m'disent "mec, si tu fais 10 bonnes réponses on t'met
premier des tendances". Quel produit coûte le moins cher ?". C'est assez flou ces 2 produits, en plus ils les
mettent bien hors contexte, on s'rend pas compte des dimensions et tout c'est ultra fourbe.
"Lequel vaut le moins cher", j'dirai quand même que c'est Grumpy Cat.
Mec ! Meeec si on a bon à celle-ci, on est premier des tendances c'est Youtube qui nous l'a dit !
On va remplacer l'enfant qui fait une blague là, "Qu'est-ce qui est jaune et qui attend", j'sais pas quoi là
Et du coup j'ai même pas regardé p*tain je saurai jamais c'que c'était qui est jaune et qui attend.
Attends faut qu'j'regarde quand même.
"- C'est quoi la blague ?
- Qu'est-ce qui est jaune et qui attend ?
- J'sais pas !
- Jonathan !
- *rires*
Bah ça mérite clairement une première place en tendances *rires*
"Quel produit coûte le moins cher ?", attention ! Oh p*tain faut qu'j'appelle un daron, faut qu'j'appelle un mec qui a des enfants !
Donc c'est genre une table pour enfants pour jouer avec de l'eau, assez grande, ou, du beurre à la vanille
"Lequel coûte le moins cher ?". La première place des tendances est en jeu
*musique épique*
Ouaiiiiiiiiiissssssssss !!!!
c'es l'début d'une nouvelle partie, j'espère faire tout aussi bien, pour peut-être rester 1h de plus dans les tendances
*rires* c'est génial le.. On dirait qu'tu veux gagner des millions alors qu'tu joues pour être dans les tendances,
c'est n'importe quoi ! Alors, "Quel produit vau 24$ ?". Un.. un.. ah comment on appelle ça ? Bon le truc dans lequel
tu mets ton thé ou ton café avant d'aller au taf, en métal, ou, un jou.. Oh il est trop bien ce jouet ! C'est ce jouet-là
qu'est à 24 ? Oh p*tain c'était le.. Bon vas-y, nan mais c'est pour du beurre.
C'est pour du beurre j'suis plus chaud, j'suis plus chaud. "Quel produit vaut 69$ ?"
J'ai acheté des raquettes de ping-pong il y a pas longtemps ! J'en ai acheté plein parce que les, les gars
d'le stream, on a.. on a heu, une table de ping-pong parce que dans un prime on jouait au ping-pong,
mais on avait plus d'raquettes et tout, j'les ai mis bien j'ai acheté des raquettes, je connais parfaitement l'prix des raquettes.
J'ai cette paire de chaussettes chez moi c'est génial ! A quel moment ça peut valoir 69$ les amis ?
On redescend sur Terre Disney s'il vous plaît. Bref tout ça pour dire qu'ce pack, les chaussette peuvent pas
valoir 69$ c'est forcément les raquettes de ping-pong. Et pour 69$ mon pote c'est de la douille !
Regardez j'vous mens pas regardez bien. "Cornilleau-lot de 2 raquettes balles 3 rouges, livré le 22 juin",
bien évidemment ça coûte 16€. C'est donc de la p*tain d'arnaque ce set de raquettes là !
"Excell 3000 Carbon, 49€80". Bon il fallait bien que je, je.. m.. m'avantage.. bon.. bon c'est moi qui achète
la raquette, j'fais c'que j'veux, si j'veux m'en prendre une bien j'm'en prend une bien *rires*
Oh nan, j'me suis fais grillé ! C'est pas c'que vous croyez la team Le Stream, j'n'ai pas acheté une raquette bien
mieux qu'les vôtres en cachette non *rires*
"Lequel coûte le plus cher ?". Oh mec, ce couteau suisse a l'air extrêmement "quali", hein on va pas d'mentir,
j'parle pas d'la ville de Cali en colombie j'parle de l'abréviation de "qualité".
ou ce Leica 20 Megapixels. Il y a de l'or sur celui-là ! J'pense la vanne c'est que le couteau suisse coûte plus cher..
C'est un gros non ! c'est un vrai mur que j'me prends en direct.
Oh p*tain là on est sur des trucs de technologie, "Lequel vaut 7$ ?"
Un truc pour ranger le téléphone ou ou un truc qui joue de la musique.
C'est le truc pour ranger ton téléphone. Voilà, a un moment faut arrêter les conneries
on se ressaisit c'est partie c'est la série de la victoire
Lequel coût 12$
du scotch arc-en-ciel avec sont support ou un livre "Aeraware"
Un livre ça coûte bien 12$ ça
* Tape sur son bureau *
Lequel coûte le plus cher ?
Un projecteur multimédia player
et smart home theater system, couleur argentée
ou un objet qui filtre l'air.
Lequel coûte le plus cher ?
C'est bien sûr le projecteur
YES !!
Là on est lancés, plus rien peut m'arrêter.
Même le puissance 4 il arrivera pas à m'arrêter.
Qu'est-ce qui coûte le plus cher, un puissance 4 ou une paire de chaussettes ...
Avec des chiens ?
M*rde. Les chaussettes Star Wars j'crois que je les avais payées genre 15 euros
Puissance 4 ?
YES !!
299 dollars !
Mais il fait 20 mètres sur 10, quoi, ton p*tain de puissance 4 !
Lequel coûte le moins cher ?
Un pollar loop crystal, on sait même pas c'que c'est , c'est du blanc sur un fond blanc,
on ne comprend pas cette image.
Ou un décapsuleur avec un motif diamant.
Qu'est-ce qui coûte le moins cher ?
Bah c'est ça !
YEEEEEESS !!
Qui peut m'stopper-é-é-é-é-é
Qu'est-ce qui vaut 59 dollars ?
Une chemise BG
que tu met à la première soirée de l'année quand tu rentres en 4e
D'ailleurs, c'est à cause de cette chemise que t'a pécho zéro meuf,
ou, oh ça c'est, ça c'est ouf, c'est ça qui vaut 59, c'est sûr
J'ai vu un écran, des outils, c'est- ça vaut 59.
On est à 8, est-ce qu'on va battre notre record ?
Qu'est-ce qui coûte le moins cher ?
Un fauteuil,
okay donc c'est une Aeron Task Chair, elle est très ajustable, les accoudoirs
sont en cuir, ou une batterie ?
La batterie est moins chère.
OOHH, c'est quoi cette chaise !
C'est quoi ça !?
1200 euros une chaise mec !
Bon après euuuuh
on connaît pas le truc, ça se trouve c'est vraiment révolutionnaire et c'est ouf mais ...
La vache !
Ah du coup j'ai eu bon !
J'ai cliqué dessus sans faire exprès, j'ai eu bon
Mais !
Est-ce qu'on va battre le record, attention
Quel produit coûte le plus cher, des Ray-Ban OU une enceinte Bluetooth
Eh un minuscule (?)
Avec dedans uuuunn
un micro.
C'est ça qui coûte le plus cher
Bah oui largement, largement !
Okay, c'est la question pour battre notre record
Oh p*tain ça va être chaud !
Quel produit coûte le moins cher ?
Le livre "Le culte du Lego"
OU, Coffee Mug
Est-ce que cette vidéo va se terminer en beauté ou pas ?
Est-ce que ma grand-mère, sera contente d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à chacune de mes p*tain de questions quand j'étais p'tit
* Musique épique
RPZ Mauricette !!
WOOOUUW !
J'étais sûr.
Et je vais expliquer le fond de ma pensée, en fait le livre,
on le voyait du dessus, ça se trouve le livre était épais comme ça
Mais on pouvait pas le savoir, vu qu'il était vu du dessus, du coup j'ai choisi la mug
* on dit un mug, squeezie x) *
Mec on continue, on va pt'être battre le créateur du site !
Méfie-toi Joe
Quel produit coûte le plus cher ?
Une sculpture de chien comme ça,
OU, un aquarium "Back to the Roots" ?
Ça
C'est la fin.
C'est officiellement la fin.
Flûte !
Hop là, p'tit tricks de foot
on m'appelle l'ovniii
Hop là !
J'ai fait tout ce qui était détestable en moins d'une seconde
* rires *
Bon les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur "The right price game.com"
J'espère que ça vous a plu, si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude
Eh ben très cool, p*tain j'ai bien géré, chu- j'suis fier de moi, en vrai hein !
J'suis assez fier de moi, même si le site dit que j'ai fait 0 points
parce que lui iiiil m'en veut, parce que j'ai géré, il est jaloux
J'ai toujours eu ce délire de deviner le prix des objets et just- en fait ça te permet juste d'avoir la valeur des choses,
d'avoir conscience de combien coûte la fabrication des objets qui t'entourent
et combien ils sont vendus en fait.
J'ai toujours aimé ça
Voilà, pt'être c'est un délire bizarre, boh c'est pas une passion, mais c'est, c'est, c'est ma curiosité quoi,
j'suis très curieux sur ça.
Enfin bref, merci d'avoir regardé,
merci à Joe de m'avoir envoyé
son... son petit site web très sympa, et puis je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Il y a plus qu'à s'en aller, comme ça...
Mamie, ça coûte combien ça ?
*Générique de fin*